bien ça arrange le métier un bon mais
c'est dommage que vous soyez contenu
parce que vous êtes quand même politique
mais bien parce qu'on sait ce sera
vraiment mais je
il met son petit matériel de bon alors
michel charasse dernière épreuve
relativement facile on ne bouge pas
est-ce qu'on peut baisser la lumière
s'il vous plaît ça ce qu'elles font donc
vous faire un petit blind test alors on
a choisi des morceaux qui vous
rappelleront le puy de dôme le petit
village dont vous êtes le maire depuis
1977 tout alors je vous demande pas le
nom des chanteurs je lui demandais que
le nom des chansons et on ne souffle pas
didier est ce que tu es prêt première
chance sable à une thèse initiale des
canards sur quelque chose comme ça
j'entends ça dans tous les bals venir la
chaîne il faut 3 la sortie je te
retrouves retrouvera j'en suis pas
encore au degré supérieur qui s'est
passé dit qu on allait on en a choisi
ses chansons parce que c'est ce que vous
entendez tous les week-ends dans le puy
de dôme
enfin souvent au bal en tout cas
deuxième chanson
comment ça s'appelle partons ça aussi
c'est s'appelle comment est-ce que
guérir dit l'adage chanson numéro 3
didier vinolas
c'est ça la question foot est lancé et
je suis maire je suis maire de ce trou
que la moindre des choses c'est peu
quand les sociétés locales font l'effort
de faire un bal et puis en plus
difficile parce qu'on a toujours le fond
que malheureusement des casseurs ou des
choses comme ça tombe bien d en parler
des vagues
pour la défense il ya parfois des balles
en province on s'amuse beaucoup mieux
que dans les dents les parisiennes ça
j'aime bien mon avis je confirme que je
suis en tournée je vais dans les boîtes
de province 6 et j'espère avoir le
plaisir de vous accueillir puis les
oliveraies
après une tournée venue des chefs avec
visuel vous avez une ouverture là à huy
a well as dit qu elle dit comme vous
j'ai jamais vu comme ça alors je vous
jure c'est la première fois que
l'ensemble on est pas content non pas du
tout bon chanson numéro sains et ne
cédez jamais dans le travail
on se doit
ça
alors son formulaire au 7 bis bien s'il
vous plaît si la maison restée stable
c'est aussi cela la tendance à sa venue
il ya pas de chat quand même dans les
bals de provenances égard il ya des
musiques plus modernes montchamp son
numéro vivier s'il te plaît
je veux
ac le groupe de l'été la tombe et là
j'ai gagné sa place sur mon plaisir
d'être avec tous ces chanteurs chanson
numéro 10
ce pas si mal finalement
je remercie de m'avoir épargné les
chansons de jeunesse étudiante très bien
michel merci beaucoup on peut allumer la
lumière car s'il te plaît alors nous
allons maintenant acquérir cette
émission à 15 heures avec quelqu'un que
lit avec quelqu'un que linda hardy adore
aussi parce que depuis qu'a eu cette
étude de france 2 suivi des études de
france 2 qui dit qu'il doit être très
très gentil avec moi mais c'est quand
même tout fait comme michel drucker
comme michel je vous souhaite la
carrière de michel drucker et 1000 da
alors un comique ça vous emmerde ce que
je dis non c'est juste plus qu'assez
norge est admiré genc de ma voisine
qu'est-ce qui les lui faisait elle m'a
dit c'est un chinois et ça dure trois
mois c'est à dire trois mois et alors
quand elle vous publicité gratuite est
le chemin le dos comme ça c'est quand
elle vous a à a on a frisé la soul est
juste passé vos ongles sur la main non
mais sur la main sur le visage la gommer
tout ce mammifère maladroit aussi une
formidable
là j'ai envie de retourner avec
dieudonné lui ni ses six filles adorent
saïda à windsor midam fois puis un peu
plus agilent en avait marre on bosse
maintenant